these HIPAA taxes will have it was my
dream to open a dental office and it
came true here in Berlin the first time
I went to a dentist here I didn't know
any German and I felt absolutely
dreadful I almost cried and at that
moment I thought to myself I don't want
other Latinos or Colombians or any other
Spanish speakers to have to go through
what I went through
despite this pretender that's me so bus
yet give me a DA bus yes
chuckling no Hoss first came to Berlin
in 1990 with her then-husband a student
at a German university at that time she
couldn't speak a word of German ja clean
and her husband eventually divorced but
she stayed on in Germany after having
cut her studies short in Colombia
she returned to dental school in Berlin
today she shares a practice with a
German dentist bulimic what I really
like about Berlin is the feeling of
freedom you can experience here you're
free to think as you wish
move around as you like here I feel I
can do whatever I want
and be whoever I want to be things are
totally different in Colombia that's
what Alice has in Colombia
nearly every year Jacqueline travels to
the country of her birth Colombia and
when she can she visits the church on
Mount Montserrat a overlooking the
capital Bogota when I was seven years
old I was hit by a car and at first my
chances of recovery didn't look so good
my father prayed a lot and made a
promise that if I got better and could
walk well again the whole family would
come here two months Ahad and fulfill
that promise it brings back a lot of
memories when I come here Bogota is the
next stop on Jacqueline's journey a
melting pot situated in a basin in the
Andes Mountains very little is left of
the city's one-time colonial charm
over nine and a half million people are
packed into this megalopolis with more
arriving all the time many are refugees
from rural areas were korilla and
paramilitary groups drug rings and
Colombian army forces are still fighting
for control of resources and power it's
estimated that more than three million
Colombians are refugees in their own
country one of Jacqueline's rituals
during her trips to Colombia is to have
a shoe shiner
give her boots a Polish but it's not
just shiny shoes she's after the media
here often published a very slanted view
of events one way to balance it out is
to talk to people in the streets
has security here gotten better or worse
here in the city centre to become better
but in the neighborhoods on the edge of
town the situation is very bad partly
because of the economy it's forcing many
people to work on the streets
competition is tough and earnings are
very poor so those working out on the
streets have to make a huge effort it's
really admirable how people like him
find ways to increase their incomes in
order to feed their families or even
provide their children with an education
that's the way it is with lots of people
who work in the streets they have a
strong will and put everything they've
got into making a living
sorry patrol when well yes
luis the shoeshine earns about six
hundred thousand pesos less than 240
euros each month
what diverse uber tile used to be very
chaotic with all the traffic jams it
could take forever to cross the city
it was congested and very dirty but I
think the Colombians have figured out
that things can only get better with
good organization and respect for others
but the city is growing faster than
planners can keep up every year 80,000
more cars are added to the already
overcrowded streets
chuckling has a date with her cousin Ana
Maria Garcia in a cafe in Bogota old
town I see Ana Maria almost every year
when I come back to Colombia I've known
her ever since we were kids
I even babysat her and her little sister
to me their family 32 year old Ana Maria
Garcia is a grand niece of the Nobel
Prize winning author Gabriel Garcia
Marquez she's trying to establish
herself as an artist in Bogota art in
Colombia is actually quite good but it's
also very exclusive only certain people
have the means to buy art it's a luxury
because most of the people here are
struggling just to buy the bare
necessities ana Maria works as a
photographer who then digitally
processes pictures her own work has been
shown in Mexico Panama and other
countries some works have fetched prices
equivalent to a few thousand euros
Anna Maria's studio is a meeting point
for many unknown artists and a few who
have made a name for themselves like 45
year old Cornell huh no he's one of the
few successful artists with an
indigenous background he takes a
critical view of current developments in
Colombia especially of the government's
neoliberal economic policies Colombian
society is very ignorant when it comes
to the visual arts capitalism devours
everything can't the government support
the arts we don't have a very
enlightened government that would help
artists if you've got a nice house and
its inhabitants have no culture then the
house falls down you see here you have
to go begging but I wasn't born to beg
those who publicly criticize political
conditions in Colombia live dangerously
union activists journalists artists
anyone who gets politically involved can
face intimidation and even death threats
artist Robert Paris has made the
violence in his country a theme in his
paintings three years now I've been
gathering information about what's going
on here from discussions and the media
and I feel more and more than as an
artist I can't remain silent child all I
ever heard about his death and massacres
and how the guerrillas were killing
people and taking away their livestock
my father's entire family were farmers
and they lost everything including their
farm at the age of 50 or 60 those poor
people were left with nothing they had
to give it all up sink where does this
entirely just okay we have Towe
the next day Jacqueline sets out for her
home city vulgar a manga outside local
town she passes a military checkpoint
just a few years ago it was still very
dangerous to drive through Colombia many
parts of the country were in the hands
of paramilitary or girl ofourse 'as
security in Colombia has gotten a lot
better there were times when I would
have been afraid but the military
checkpoints along the way helped give me
the feeling that I'm protected that
nothing can happen to me here that's
good it gives us a sense of freedom in
our own country that unfortunately still
has problems the problem had
after four hours on the road Jacqueline
arrives at the town of chicken Kira a
key religious site in Colombia it's
believed that over four centuries ago
the Virgin Mary appeared to a simple
farmer here now hundreds of thousands of
the faithful make the pilgrimage to the
Basilica every year Jacqueline is
herself a devout Catholic along with
over 80 percent of Colombia's 45 million
people
chuckling asks a Dominican monk father
Narciso Gomez to bless some rosaries for
her father of merciful love pour forth
thy blessings upon my daughter
Jacqueline upon her hands upon her work
so that her deeds will be a sign of the
blessings protection and love of God
most Colombians are deeply religious and
attend Mass regularly but here too the
scandals over misuse of authority and
sexual abuse have dealt a severe blow to
the reputation of the Catholic Church
Maria para que Maria the protecta para
que Maria's here to hear creo que like
católica tambien esta I believe the
Catholic Church is aware that it has to
renew itself not in its principles but
the people the Catholics themselves you
have to renew themselves what I want to
say is that we as Catholics have to
practice what we preach how most boy in
this program a Muslim from chicken Kiera
the journey continues northeast across
the high valleys of the Cordillera
oriental or eastern range of the Andes
after 200 kilometers twisting and
turning through the mountains chuckling
comes to Socorro a town she often
visited with her family when she was a
little girl today she wants to visit her
aunt it was in her house that Jacqueline
had her very first experience with
something she now deals with on a daily
basis in her job Medicine
just a moon with your sexy toes Jaclyn's
and burt Adira Gillis runs the town's
oldest pharmacy it was started by
Jacqueline's grandfather in Columbia the
pharmacies are called throat areas or
drug stores they sell almost any
medication without a prescription a
practice left over from the days when
there were hardly any doctors in rural
areas as a little girl Jacqueline got to
watch her grandfather mix his own
medicines in the cellar under the shop
to me a visit to my grandpa's pharmacy
was like going to Disneyland for an
American kid I was fascinated with all
these little drawers and how colorful it
all was and with all the medicines with
their odd names and just with the smell
of the medicine it seemed maybe that had
an influence on my career choice later
on when I'm in my practice and notice
the smell of medicine then I feel secure
uh clean and Durant have a lot more to
talk about than stories of days gone by
they also discussed the health problems
afflicting the population of Columbia
nowadays and Bretta says eating habits
have changed radically with drastic
consequences people today are suffering
from rheumatism gout and cancer people
used to be quite a lot healthier than
they are now my father for instance died
at the age of 80 years and seven months
he was strong as a No
chuckling arrives in the next village
cinema Kota just in time for the town
festival a bullfight is the highlight of
the event
the Spanish brought the tradition of
bullfighting to Latin America and it
struck deep roots in Colombia
I'm Judy doh
we see the terreiro not as a coward but
just the opposite a symbol of courage he
dares to face an enraged animal and play
with it and if you've experienced that
as a child you don't associate it with
violence but with the Fiesta you
associate it with fun and a chance to
meet with family and friends
nice lesson from chameleon on from there
in this case the bullfight mainly
provides a backdrop for the visitors
enjoyment in many other arenas in the
countryside and especially in major
cities a bullfight still ends with a
dead bull but in Seema Kota the bull
leaves the arena alive in Colombia to
animal rights activists are making
headway
the last leg of the journey takes
jackeline through some more spectacular
mountain scenery the Chickamauga Canyon
is the biggest in Colombia from here
it's only about 120 kilometers to
Jaclyn's hometown Bucaramanga where she
spent the first 21 years of her life
Bucaramanga is the prosperous capital of
santander department with more than 1
million people in its metropolitan area
its economy is based on trade with
nearby Venezuela it has a reputation of
being safe and clean compared to other
major Colombian cities
but all around the outskirts of Bulgaria
slums are proliferating a consequence of
uncontrolled population growth and
people being driven from their homes in
the country they're forced to settle in
areas not fit for habitation every year
during the rainy season hundreds or even
thousands of people die in mudslides
most of them poor Jacque leaves family
has long been politically active during
ten years as mayor and city councilor
her father dedicated his efforts to
narrowing the gap between rich and poor
on a finger a ranch in the mountains
chuckling sees her parents again for the
first time in a year
every year usually on epiphany January
the sixth the family arranges a big
gathering relatives from all over even
from abroad attend if they can
Jaclyn's parents have also left Colombia
they moved to Venezuela in 1996 for
their own safety
her father Jose had been kidnapped by
left-wing guerrillas and released after
a ransom was paid enough Colombia it's a
very beautiful country but for over 60
years now it's had a problem the
guerrillas you can't fight the guerillas
with violence you can only fight them
with social projects people living at
the edges of society have to be
reintegrated they have to be able to get
an education so they can get jobs and
not hang out on the streets and turn to
criminal that's the solution for
Colombia humanitarian Colombia's
notorious for kidnappings but the
numbers have dropped radically from
about 3500 in two thousand two hundred
three hundred and twenty ten my father
has the character of a politician he
used to be 1 years ago I've always known
him as a public figure he used to take
me along during election campaigns and
to his speeches and I've always known
him as someone who identifies very
strongly with sometimes there someone
who fights very hard for the rights of
disadvantaged people to me that's always
been a very strong motivation in my own
life I mean the grocer motivation in
mind even gave ISM
for sure clean the hardest part of every
trip to Bucaramanga is the visit to her
brother's grave in 1987 at the age of 23
hey soos Oswaldo Rojas was killed in an
automobile accident the cemetery
personnel tend the grave for most of the
year my family is my greatest support I
miss that a lot in Germany and that may
be what I'm looking for when I come back
this love this closeness and support
that give me the strength I need to keep
on living in Germany
chuckling goes to visit her best friend
in Bucaramanga pilar Galvez lives in an
apartment block in the center of town
the women have known each other since
primary school they even went to dental
college together in spite of the
geographical distance between them their
friendship is closer than ever over the
years Jacqueline has described her life
in Berlin in long letters to be long
after reminiscing for a while
pilar suggests that Jacqueline have a
look at where she works at her new job
in the nearby town of Huron
[ __ ] on is a colonial town that grew
rich on the tobacco grown in the region
pill our works in a medical center that
caters to patients covered by national
health insurance
in Colombia employers are required to
register their staff with the national
health insurance company and when the
workers need health care they can't go
to doctors and clinics of their own
choosing but only those under contract
with their insurance companies the
treatment may be affordable but it can
also be rather basic several patients
might even receive treatment in the same
room separated only by a screen by
European standards the conditions are
fairly rudimentary dentists under
contract with such facilities earn a
fixed salary of about one thousand euros
a month many of them hold down two jobs
most of the doctors here work under
contract and maintain a private practice
on the side but I work only here and the
rest of the time I look after my family
I found out it's why the idea of a
dentist having two jobs that they might
work for these state medical centers
from say 6 a.m. to 1 p.m. and then after
a short lunch break work in their own
practices on private patients from 2 to
8 p.m. even on Saturdays well I think
that's pretty tough I still got some
stuff as it does does Hindi hurt coming
back to Colombia once a year for a visit
is one thing but returning permanently
to live and work is something jackeline
can't imagine studying in Germany and
establishing herself there
professionally cost her a lot of time
and effort she's accomplished something
that few of her colleagues in Colombia
could even dream of something Jacqueline
wouldn't give up easily my head my home
is where my heart is
and my heart belongs to two places
bukata manga and berlin look at a manga
is where I spent my childhood where I
first fell in love but when I left for
Germany my second life started and I'm
inseparably connected to Berlin because
I arrived
there in 1990 just when Berlin was also
undergoing a transformation two worlds
came together just like two worlds were
coming together in my own head